scp-682 vs scp-165  could the hard-to-destroy reptile  finally be devoured by the combined  forces of the creeping hungry sands of  tool a large  scp-165 sample was placed beneath a trap  door with scp-682 positioned above it  when the monster was dropped into the  hill of teeming flesh-eating mites they  began devouring it it was engulfed in  the dunes and remained there for 10  minutes before the dune ceased activity  and a much smaller version of  scp-682 crawled out the fire eaters were  called in to blast both and returned 682  to its containment chamber in all  likelihood 682 had admitted a pesticide  that killed off the mites while a  smaller version of itself hid inside its  own skull until it was safe to emerge  and attempt to escape